grade three teacher christy chippenock
hasn't been able to eat lunch in the
staff room ever since her sense of smell
got messed up
garlic and onions are really bad so if
i'm walking down the hallway i'll be
like oh my gosh like it's just so and it
i feel rude obviously doing that but
there's nothing i had to buy a nose plug
it started in february a couple of
months after she had coveted 19. her
toothpaste suddenly tasted rancid and
her favorite drink coffee smelled like
gasoline sometimes she smells hair spray
or vomit all day there are very few
things she can eat
meat is a no-no meat smells and tastes
rotten completely the condition is
called perosmia and it's becoming more
common as covid infects more people the
nose is that is the port of entry so
this is why we had especially the
original variant so many people that
complained about the sense of smell dr
johannes fresnelli specializes in smell
research his team followed hundreds of
health care workers infected at the
beginning of the pandemic who had any
smell issues after five months one fifth
developed perasmia after a year that
number had grown to half
so we have these sniffing sticks he says
smell training can help some patients so
we actually think that the exposure to
those odorants helps the olfactory
receptor neurons the neurons in the nose
regenerate from from
stem cells that we have there dr carl
philpott in the uk is also studying
perasmia his theory is covid affects the
receptors in the nose for example you
take the smell of a rose 13 different
molecules that could have make up that
smell and if you can only pick up six or
seven of them you're getting a different
signal so you're going to get in pieces
of the jigsaw and it smells wrong the
smells were smelling like they are not
like they are atrocious christy's
beloved coffee maker sits unused and her
diet consists mostly of avocados she
says her co-workers and students are
supportive but the condition can be
depressing
it is
so isolating sue lingo global news